[Music]
every single po trick you ever learn
will involve some challenges but some of
those challenges are pretty deceptively
hidden by the appearance of the trick
Drex here from drexfactor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I counting down five
deceptively difficult po tricks that
happen to be personal favorites but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro ter light toys spinballs
and Ultra for helping them make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
so straight up anytime you learn a PO
trick you're going to have to go through
a process of figuring out how to make
all the little kinesthetic elements of
it work with your own body those
challenges are absolutely real no matter
what trick you happen to be working on
but I do think that we sometimes judge a
book by its cover and see a pyric that
either looks like it's going to be
simple or looks similar to something
that we already know and assume then
that the learning curve is going to be a
quite gentle one and so with that in
mind I have a assembled a list of five
of the PO tricks that I think are the
most deceptively difficult and some of
these really annoy me because they
tricks that we throw at beginners all
the time caveats of course everybody has
their own flow journey and some people
are going to find that the tricks that
I'm including on this list are easier
than others but overall aggregated
together with all the experiences of
students I've had over the years these
are the ones that whenever we got into
it I knew I had a challenge ahead of me
so without further Ado let's let's dive
in trick number one tuck
turns so tuck turns are a really
interesting case cuz they're basically
just a step up from a p trick that I
think is deceptively easy which is just
performing extensions with your hands in
together Time same direction but it's
that little Loop that they add behind
your shoulders and waist that can be a
little tricky see I like training the
top part of Tuck turns because gravity
helps you out you can simply just drop
the poy back behind your back and things
turn out swimmingly but it's that pedal
on bottom where the poy are fighting
against gravity that the challenge
really kicks in and honestly this kind
of annoys me because tuck turns are an
integral step into learning body tracers
and I've had a lot of students go
through the process of learning how to
do them and I just have never found a
technique that I really like for
teaching the bottom part of this move if
you've got a good technique for teaching
the bottom part of this please let me
know down in the comments cuz I could
really use the help help that said we
are now going to depart the land of
beginner tricks and start to get into
stuff that I think everybody can agree
is actually quite difficult trick number
two
isolations uh isolations one of the few
poy tricks where it is very very very
easy to understand the concept and
Incredibly difficult to actually
physically perform it after all the idea
behind an isolation is simply that
you're going to spin the POI around the
center of the tether your hand and the
poy head are both going around the same
Circle just at opposite ends oh but
goodness getting down the technique to
actually do this and make it look good
it takes forever back in the day I
remember when po juggling Phenom Keith
Marshall visited me here in DC and we
had a day discussing if there were any
poy tricks that were as difficult to
learn as juggling tricks and the
isolation was the one and only one that
we could come up with basically there's
no way around the the fact that this
move just requires an incredible amount
of woodshedding you need to put in the
hours to get down the technique and try
to perfect it and even then there's
going to be moments when it drifts in
and out of alignment you've just got to
do your best with it so we have
isolations which I think everybody can
agree just take a lot of work to get
down so what could be harder than
isolations well tricks that require
isolations trick number three isolation
versus horizontal cat eye yeah I know
putting this in isol ations on the same
list is is kind of double dipping in
some ways but I do have one very
specific reason why I wanted to put this
trick on this list so here's the thing a
lot of the tech poy tricks that we
played with back in the day wound up
becoming stuff that is more or less
standard in the PO spinning world today
and I always expected this trick to wind
up on that list and even after a decade
and a half it has stubbornly refused to
become a standard one and it's not hard
to understand why in addition to being
being able to do isolations with it one
also has to learn how to do horizontal
cat eyes cat eyes in and of themselves
can be a challenge but putting them on a
horizontal axis is something that will
Boggle even the most advanced po mines
it seems weird right because both of the
poy are just doing a single beat move
and yet when you put these pieces
together it becomes an incredibly
difficult to solve puzzle many have
tried few have succeeded all right so I
do have to say there is going to be a
massive step up in
difficulty trick number four the
one-handed
Mercedes I know I know I know who
actually thinks that this is an easy
Point trick thing is I remember back in
the day when we were working this one
out and absolutely everybody who was
trying already knew how to do the
Mercedes with two hands and we were
absolutely stumped as to what was going
wrong when we were trying to do it with
just the one hand as it turns out all of
those fine plane adjustments that are
necessary to make the Mercedes work are
really hard to do with just one hand not
only are you having to do a timing
change with the poy but also you have to
switch which PO is in front in between
each point it's quite a big puzzle I
remember back in the day seeing so many
people who were really good at poy
really struggling with this move somehow
the pieces were just so difficult to put
together that it would stump even
incredibly skilled Spinners it may not
look like an easy trick to those of you
who are at the beginning of your flow
Journey but trust me for those of us
who'd been at it for a while when meteor
style POI became a big thing it looked
like it should be something that
wouldn't be that difficult for us to
learn goodness we we ever wrong all
right so before I share with you my
final pick for five deceptively
difficult poy tricks uh I do have a
favor to ask see if you've come this far
I'm pretty sure that you're into poy
tricks and po spinning in general and if
that's the case then you're in luck
because I make lots of videos about POI
and POI spinning if you'd like to get
all of my latest videos as soon as they
come out please subscribe subbe to the
channel and ring that Bell so that you
are one of the first to know now with
all that said my number one pick for
deceptively difficult poy tricks
is Trick number five the three beat
weave wait so have I gotone absolutely
barking mad and stuck one of the most
common P tricks in the world at the top
of this list of difficult P tricks above
isolations above the one-handed Mercedes
yes because I personally think that it's
kind of of a cruel joke that we play on
beginners the 3B weave requires several
overlapping skills all working perfectly
in concert whether it's the ability to
keep the pois spinning split times same
direction do tic tacs going back and
forth across the body or that most
difficult step of all figuring out how
to get in the extra beat when your hand
is crossed across your body like I know
this move is considered very Elementary
and a big part of that is just that this
is one of those few things that appears
in absolutely every every culture that
has ever created a prop that is a weight
on the end of a string but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's an intuitive
thing to learn this is part of the
reason why I've shied away from teaching
the 3B weave is one of the first few
tricks that I give to beginners I prefer
to give people stuff that feels a little
bit more intuitive and gets them to feel
more comfortable with the tools straight
up things like reels and extensions
before I dropped them into the deep end
with this very very very deceptively
difficult monster so that is why it is
my final pick for poy tricks that are
deceptively hard did you also find that
these po tricks were deceptively
difficult are there some other tricks
that you discovered along your flow
Journey that wound up being a bigger
challenge than you were expecting please
leave me a comment and let me
know
the videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd like to
single out my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right here if you like
the work that I do please consider
signing up to support me over at
patreon.com Factor poy there's a lot of
stuff that I have to do to bring income
in the door and the more people support
me on patreon the more time I'm able to
invest in creating these videos for you
and everybody in the world so go check
that out please and thank you and hey if
you dug this video on five po tricks
that are deceptively difficult maybe
you'll enjoy this video on five poy
tricks that are deceptively easy hey the
other end of the spectrum thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care now peace